thank you so much for coming i'm excited
to be here
at data council austin
to discuss leveling up your data lake
with delta and lakefs
my name is paul i'm a developer advocate
at
lake fess
before that was a data engineer at
several companies in the new york area
i'm interested in
democratizing big data
for people to feel confident to use it
for their personal interests
unfortunately my co-speaker adi could
not make it
but we will
persevere nonetheless
so
we're going to today discuss in a pretty
quick little talk um i have prepared
on
covering what is a basic data lake what
it looks like what it's good for
and
then some improvements we can make to up
uh the level of our data lake game
with uh table
formats and data version control
so we will start
from the bottom and work our way up
to the top
so a data lake is primarily two things
it is an object store and the objects
being stored
your main object stores are the main
cloud providers services like amazon s3
google blob and um sorry azure blob and
google cloud storage
as well as some interesting open source
solutions like the now
1 billion dollar worth
valuated min io
and a couple other options
and if you're just getting started with
a data lake you might have something
like
csv files that
every day you save under a date
partition path
and with this basic architecture
you are
in a pretty good spot to
handle all of the use cases for data
like
business intelligence machine learning
model development and
data intensive apis or operational
analytics
and the
uh the flexibility
to do all of these the fact that you can
do all these different use cases speaks
to the flexibility of object stores
and sort of their strength
they're pretty ubiquitously used from
what i see and
people kind of take them for granted so
i think it's worth taking a
couple minute interlude to
remind ourselves of some of their
features and strengths
so
why why use object storage for data
besides the fact that they are
kind of meant to store data but they're
pretty awesome in terms of a number
of categories performance cost developer
experience and the fact that they can
connect to
pretty much every data tool that i've
ever come across
and to give you some specifics
in terms of performance they will
automatically scale to thousands of put
and get requests per prefix
the scaling happens like automatically
behind the scenes
and gives you almost like unlimited
capacity
besides for some notable
um times like the entire internet went
down when like s3 went down they're
pretty reliable and available at least
compared to anything you might self-host
you will pay for two things when using
an object store the storage and the
network costs
and
they are
compared to the comparable
block storage that you'll find in a
database they're pretty cost effective
about five to eight times cheaper
according to what i saw online and
my personal experience
no one has ever opened up their aws bill
and been outraged at their their s3
costs
they have a pretty great developer
experience it's very easy to connect to
them there's no clunky
database connection strings that have
always caused me headaches and whatever
language you use there's probably a
mature client sdk to read and write data
from them
two newer features that have come out in
the s3 ecosystem in the last few years
that
i'm happy to point out are
[Music]
strong consistency
which means when you write an object
you're guaranteed for it to come back in
a subsequent read very impressive for
such a large scale distributed system
and
aws storage lens which gives you
out of the box just very nice usage um
graphs over time per bucket per prefix
you don't have to set up this monitoring
monitoring yourself you can catch
if you're like um you know some some
particular buckets storage is out of
control helps you catch it
comes automatically if you haven't
checked it out
and they're much more um object stores
have a lot more features than just being
like dropbox for developers
um you can set up data replication
policies my personal favorite event
notifications
and um you know set up permissioning on
on
on the prefix level
uh there's a lot uh
there's a lot going on
and finally
whether using um you know spark or
snowflake or presto trino kafka
all these tools pretty much know how to
speak the object store language and
it serves as a nice sort of common layer
of interoperability between these tools
so it's a little bit about object stores
why i think they're pretty great why
they are
um very widely used
and
um
also the company i work for like fess
the logo just appeared in the box also
knows how to work with object stores as
we'll cover a bit later
so
um while object stores are great
they um
they're pretty general purpose tools and
when using them for data there are a
number of
you know analytics specific improvements
we can make to make them even better
and this is kind of because
unlike in a database where the storage
is very um
obfuscated to the end user
in object stores
it's you know right out in front this
has its pros and cons
as the downside you can find yourself
managing kind of low level file problems
that maybe you shouldn't be dealing with
but on the pro side
we are open to customize
how the object store
works
in certain ways as we'll cover
so
this is our basic
data lake using object store let's uh
make some improvements to it
and the first and most obvious
improvement we can make is to replace
those
pesky csv files
that
no one really likes
so
what we can a pretty simple improvement
we can do is use the parquet file format
which is uh it's open source
and it has a number of benefits like
being columnar
and the way it stores the data it is
highly compressible and
it can support complex data types
and
while this is great unfortunately
however optimized
parquet files can be
we are still for the most part
dealing with
collections of files or objects which
isn't super fun
so
what's missing
and we can borrow from the database
world here is the abstraction of a table
so to get to the next level we can
introduce modern table formats to our
data lake and this provides the
abstraction familiar from databases of a
table
and
this provides a number of benefits
so we can define schema on a collection
of data
we can give the tables like human
readable friendly names that we can
remember more easily than a path in an
object store
we can traverse the
versions of the
we can traverse the hit the history of
updates of the table
and um
and up and update the tables atomically
so if anyone's
used an object store
without these table formats when you're
writing data to
under certain prefix and then try to
read the data you might get a query
error saying that like a file is being
manipulated in the middle of the read
you might get strange inconsistent
results because like half the file has
been committed and this solves that
problem
these table formats which
the most popular implementations are
apache hoodie apache iceberg
and delta lake
they keep a transaction log of all the
files that are added and deleted
from the table
as a piece of metadata that sits
alongside the data itself
this diagram is an example of like how
delta lake works with the delta log
directory
and
in that is a transaction log that
says
you know park hey file1 added park k2
file removed and when reading the table
into a data frame something like spark
it will know to
read that transaction log to see which
files should be included
so
this greatly improves the manageability
of our data lake
but we can further improve it
by adding a new layer of abstraction
of data version control
and here we see the new layer
which is provided by creating
a repository
a data repository in which branches of
in which branches can be managed that
contain the
table objects
from the table formats
so
we get
a lot of the same benefits
from data version control
that we got from the table formats but
these can span
at the level of an entire data lake
across tables
so
basically
within a data repository we are able to
perform certain git like operations and
apply them to
data sets in object storage
so we can
take a commit of a branch
which saves a snapshot of
all the tables at a specific point in
time
we can create branches
and
add changes to one of them and then
merge them back
and
you know look at the history of these
commits and and
traverse among them as needed
so
two the the two most popular
implementations of this are the lakefest
project which i
um contribute to
and work for and there's another one
called project nessie as well
so to make it a bit more clear
how this works
uh and like when it's used we can look
at these these operations
um
we have a
you know these are all things well you
can't do these but
it helps simplify
[Music]
managing the complex workflows that are
done over modern data lakes and to help
spell it out
here's some examples of the command
you'd run
in late control our cli tool
and
what what it's useful for so
if you have a
error that makes it into your production
tables that maybe get exposed to
external users or an important dashboard
you can use the revert command to
send the data back to a previously known
good snapshot of the data
and this lets you instantly recover from
data data quality issues while you maybe
troubleshoot the root cause and fix
it um
so you might have two data sets that you
want to keep in sync
and this can be tricky
if you're
definitely on the ob if you're operating
on the object level even on the table
level it's hard to update two tables at
the same time
what you can do with these get like
workflows is create a branch add changes
to both tables on the
new branch and then perform a merge
operation to atomically update the to
atomically expose the data
for both tables
similarly
i'm sure everyone has
made a copy of a table that they wanted
to make a change on with their like
initials or the date or some other
manual marker
and this is a luxury you can do at
smaller scales of data
and it's also not very manageable when
you have a bunch of people trying to
make changes
when you
would like fs if you create a branch you
get an isolated
development environment that contains a
copy of all the data sets in your
repository
and it does not duplicate the data
until you make a change so
it's very cost effective and
lets multiple people
you know change things simultaneously
without worrying about how it affects
others
and finally
this is a common machine learning use
case you want to run an experiment you
want it to be reproducible someone else
a month later can run the same
experiment
and
confirm the results but it's not easy to
reproduce the state the data was at that
exact time
if you take a commit then you will have
a generated commit id you can reference
to pull in the state of those tables at
that time
so
that is the main
ways to level up your data lakes if
you're operating at the
file level you should
not and consider
operating at the table and the
repository level
so
thank you very much
if you want to check out more
you can go to lakefest.io to read our
documentation check out our blog we have
a
slack community
as well
which
a lot of helpful people
we have a
playground environment in which you can
try out
using lakefs over datasets
and
[Music]
thank you very much happy to answer any
questions